I was I was switching back to the uh to the to the other podcast we're recording this is gonna it's like inception it's like inception there's a podcast inside the podcast welcome to ADSP the podcast episode, recorded on February 13th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about Microsoft Excel. Perfect intro, perfect intro to why Excel is the... So why are we talking about Excel? Did we say... I feel like at the end of one of our podcasts in a section that got cut, Excel came up and then you said,
我正在切换回我们正在录制的另一个播客，这感觉就像是盗梦空间，就像是盗梦空间，播客里面还有一个播客。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客节目，录制于 2021 年 2 月 13 日。我的名字是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论微软 Excel。完美的开场，完美解释了为什么 Excel 是……那么，我们为什么要谈论 Excel？我们是不是说过……我觉得在我们其中一期播客里，在某个被剪掉的片段中，提到了 Excel，然后你说，
you said, I'm the best at Excel. I do not think... And then I think I was like... I think I expressed a proficiency for Excel. You know what? I'm going to go back through all our... I think I know which episode it is. So I don't I'm going to go back through all our, I think I know which episode it is, so I don't think I need to go back through all 12.
你说，我是 Excel 最强者。我不认为……然后我觉得我好像……我觉得我表达了对 Excel 的精通。你知道吗？我要回过头去查看我们所有的……我想我知道是哪一期。所以我不用……我要回过头去查看我们所有的，我想我知道是哪一期，所以我觉得我不需要重新翻看所有 12 期。
I'm going to find the clip, and I'm going to cut it in, and we're going to see what Bryce said. I think Bryce said he was the goat at Excel, and then I just said, hold your horses. Hold your horses, Bryce. I used to have three different Excel programs, 2003, 2007, and 2010, all at the same
我要找到那个片段，然后把它剪辑进去，看看布莱斯当时说了什么。我觉得布莱斯说他是 Excel 的 GOAT（历史最佳），然后我只是说，别急。别急，布莱斯。我以前同时在电脑上安装了三个不同的 Excel 程序，
time installed on my computer because I loved Excel so much. And I just, Excel gets... I believe you referred to yourself as the Excel wizard. Oh yeah, that's for sure. Honestly, so here's an anecdote. Here's an anecdotal story. Back in 2011, I was interviewing for my first internship or first co-op or internship. I was in, what is that, third year going in, I was in third year university. called Manulife, which at the time owned the American insurance company John Hancock, which is the company I ended up working at in Toronto. And they asked me at one point, how would you rate yourself on a scale of 1 to 10 in Excel? And I'm a pretty modest, at that time, you know, I'd like to think I'm a pretty modest guy so instead of giving myself a 10 out of 10 i said you know there's probably some room for improvement and i gave myself a 9 out of 10 but i i gave the some color commentary so i said you know i don't i don't want to say i'm perfect so i want to leave some room for improvement i'm a nine-year-old. What did you use Excel for before you were working? Like graphs.
2003、2007 和 2010 版，因为我太爱 Excel 了。而且我只是，Excel 获得……我记得你自称为 Excel 巫师。哦，对，那是肯定的。说实话，这里有一个轶事。这是一个关于我个人的小故事。早在 2011 年，我正在面试我的第一份实习或第一个带薪实习工作。我当时在读大几，不对，我是大三。那家公司叫宏利（Manulife），当时它拥有美国保险公司约翰汉考克（John Hancock），也就是我后来在多伦多工作的那家公司。他们有一次问我：“在 1 到 10 的范围内，你如何评价自己的 Excel 水平？”我是一个相当谦虚的人，当时呢，我自认为是个相当谦虚的人，所以没有给自己打 10 分，我说：“你知道的，可能还有一些改进的空间”，我给自己打了 9 分。但我也做了一些补充说明，我说：“你知道的，我不想说我很完美，所以我想留出一点改进的空间，我是一个 9 分得主。”你在工作之前用 Excel 做什么？比如图表。
I thought that your passion for Excel came out of your brief stint as an actuarial scientist. It sounds like it predates that. It sounds like it may have been the other way around. You were like a nerd about Excel and then you decided you should become an actuarial scientist. No, no. So here's the punchline of the story is, you know, so I'm there thinking that I know everything there is to know about Excel. In hindsight, with the knowledge that I have now about what you can do with Excel, I would give myself a zero out of ten at that point in time.
我以为你对 Excel 的热情源于你短暂的精算师职业生涯。听起来这比那还要早。听起来可能恰恰相反。你曾经是个 Excel 迷，然后你决定成为一名精算师。不，不。所以这个故事的妙处在于，你知道的，我当时觉得我知道关于 Excel 的一切。事后看来，以我现在对 Excel 功能的了解，在那时我会给自己打零分。
I didn't even know what a pivot table was. I didn't know that you could filter rows. I literally knew like nothing about Excel, but I just didn't I didn't know Sorry? You didn't know you could filter rows? I didn't know anything. Like it's, it's comical that, but that's the thing is you don't know what you don't know. You know, it's people don't ever think that they have a bad memory because they don't remember what they've forgotten.
我甚至不知道什么是数据透视表。我不知道你可以筛选行。我真的对 Excel 一无所知，但我只是不知道……抱歉？你不知道你可以筛选行？我什么都不知道。这简直，简直太滑稽了，但这就是问题所在——你不知道你所不知道的。你知道的，人们从不认为自己记性不好，因为他们不记得自己忘记了什么。
Right? Anyways, so at the time I, I thought knew about Excel. And then I ended up getting the job there and I went and worked for eight months. And that was where I had my eyes opened. And I came across this one file that was used for calculating, I don't know, some basis points on some boring insurance product. But you open up the file and you click a macro button and then this form popped up. And it was like a full-blown computer program. And I was like, what the hell is this? Like, this is not the Excel that I know.
对吧？不管怎样，当时我以为自己懂 Excel。然后我最终在那里得到了这份工作，去工作了八个月。也就是在那里，我大开眼界。我偶然看到一个文件，它是用来计算什么的，我不知道，某个无聊保险产品的某些基点。但是你打开文件，点击一个宏按钮，然后这个表单就弹出来了。它就像一个成熟的计算机程序。当时我就想，这到底是什么鬼？这根本不是我认识的 Excel。
And then I was like, started clicking on things. And I was like, this is a full-blown program. And sure enough, like the Visual Basic VBA, Visual Basic Application Code was like, the worksheet was protected. So then I spent like half a day figuring out how to hack Excel 2003 with a hex editor, which was pretty simple back in the day. So I hacked the file, and got access to the source code. And then it was just like I had entered the matrix. And it was honestly like, I... i is before you were programming yeah this was before and so this is the thing is i was an actuarial science major at the time i went and did my eight months at manulife slash john hancock and then i came out of it and i was like i have to double major
然后我就开始点击各种东西，心想：这是一个成熟的程序！果真如此，Visual Basic VBA，即 Visual Basic 应用程序代码……工作表被保护了。于是我花了半天时间研究如何用十六进制编辑器破解 Excel 2003，这在当年其实挺简单的。所以我破解了文件，获取了源代码。然后那种感觉就像我进入了黑客帝国（The Matrix）。老实说，就像我……这发生在你开始编程之前，对吧？是的，这在此之前。这就是重点，我当时是精算科学专业，在宏利/约翰汉考克做完了八个月的实习，出来之后我就想：我必须双修
in computer science like like computer science is the future because I had fallen into the matrix that was Excel. And it's just unbelievable. And also, too, I use the best color palette that I've ever come across was in Excel 2003. There's like a pastel default color palette. I'll find a way. Actually, all of my Google Translate algorithm comparison like screenshots where show filter in 20 different programming languages, that uses the color scheme from Excel 2003. I went and got the exact hex codes for those colors and embedded them into the Clojure script that generates those pictures because it's just beautiful. It's like Easter it's happy it just it makes me you know they really dropped the ball when they
计算机科学，因为计算机科学就是未来。因为我已经坠入了名为 Excel 的黑客帝国。这简直难以置信。而且，我用过最棒的配色方案是在 Excel 2003 中。那里有一种默认的柔和配色方案。我会想办法的。实际上，我所有的 Google 翻译算法比较截图——展示了在 20 种不同编程语言中的筛选——都使用了 Excel 2003 的配色方案。我特意去找到了这些颜色的精确十六进制代码，并将它们嵌入到生成这些图片的 Clojure 脚本中，因为它们实在太美了。它就像复活节一样充满生机与快乐，它真的让你……当他们
went to 2007 and added the ribbon and then they changed the color schemes to be these crappy you know one color different shades you know green you know orange anyways we should start to talk about why you know how do you feel about google sheets i have a soft place in my heart for all spreadsheet programs so like anyone that says google sheets is excel like doesn't know anything about excel mac excel is not excel libra office whatever sheets or whatever it's called, that's not Excel. Excel is hands down like only Excel on Windows or like Linux Wine. Although I've never used Linux Wine, but I think it's just the same thing. What about Office 365 Excel? That's the online one, right?
在 2007 年转版并添加功能区（Ribbon），然后将配色方案改成那些糟糕的、单一颜色只有不同色调的方案（比如绿色、橙色）时，他们真的把事情搞砸了。不管怎样，我们应该开始讨论为什么……你对谷歌表格（Google Sheets）有什么看法？我内心深处对所有电子表格程序都有一份温存。所以，任何说谷歌表格就是 Excel 的人，根本不懂 Excel。Mac 上的 Excel 不是 Excel，LibreOffice 的表格或无论它叫什么，那也不是 Excel。毫无疑问，Excel 只有 Windows 版的 Excel，或者像 Linux Wine 上的。虽然我从未用过 Linux Wine，但我觉得它俩是一回事。Office 365 Excel 怎么样？那是网页版的，对吧？
Yeah. I have not played with that enough. For for the times that I've gone and used it. It's done. It's been able to do everything that I've tried to do in the browser. All right. Time for me to tell an embarrassing Microsoft story. Microsoft will never be a sponsor of this podcast after this. I'm sure. I, I, about a year ago I had, it was a dot doc so not a dot doc x but um a dot doc file so like a 2003 um uh word file that i'm pretty sure it was an iso or insights thing so it was it was some form that one of the standards bodies i worked with had sent me and um i wanted to have it it was it was something we needed to fill out for like a response to some it was a response to some iso thing i think it was like comments on whether we wanted to retire some old standards but it had to be filled out in a certain form
对。我没有充分体验过它。就我过去使用它的几次经历来看。它已经完成了。它能够做到我在浏览器中尝试做的一切。好了。该轮到我讲一个令人尴尬的微软故事了。经历了这件事之后，微软绝对不会成为这个播客的赞助商了，我敢肯定。我，大约在一年前，我有一个 .doc 文件——不是 .docx 文件，而是一个 .doc 文件，就像一个 2003 年的……呃，Word 文件。我确信那是一个 ISO 或某种标准组织的文件。那是我合作过的某个标准制定机构发给我的某种表单。呃，我想把它……它是我需要填写并用于回复某个 IT 事项的东西，我记得是关于我们是否想废除一些旧标准的意见征集，但它必须以某种特定格式填写。
so i'm like all right i'm gonna stick it in, in, in, you know, Office Online, and then everybody will be able to comment on it. And I, I uploaded it through Office Online. And it was like, hey, we're gonna have to convert your file. I'm like, okay, and I press OK, it completely crapped out on converting this file, like completely misformed. So I went and tried it with Google Docs, did it perfectly. So I'm not saying that Google's online versions of Microsoft Office Suite are better than real Office Suite. They're certainly not. But I am saying I'm pretty sure that they're better than Microsoft's online version of the Office suite. I don't doubt that at all.
所以我心想：好吧，我要把它放到 Office Online 中，这样每个人都能对它进行评论。然后我通过 Office Online 上传了它。结果它提示说：“嘿，我们得转换你的文件。”我说：“好的”，然后点击了“确定”。结果它在转换这个文件时彻底崩溃了，排版完全走样了。于是我去用 Google Docs（谷歌文档）试了一下，完美转换。所以我并不是说微软 Office 套件的网页版比真正的 Office 套件更好。它们肯定不如。但我想说的是，我确信它们比微软的网页版 Office 套件要好。对此我毫不怀疑。
And I will say that for the use cases that the majority of people, like I'd probably say 99% of folks that use Google Sheets, for what they're using it for, it's amazing. You do not need excel for you know you know for example when i played you know uh what do you call it co-ed soccer in toronto with some fellow actuaries we would you know have the schedule and attendance and whoever was showing up we did that all in google sheets like you do not need excel for that that's a very that's a very actuarial thing to do yeah yeah or like whenever the actual at my at my where i started my career whenever we would go out for uh this is gonna sound so lame whenever we would go out for like some fancier dinner or
而且我要说的是，对于大多数人的使用场景来说——我大概可以说使用谷歌表格的 99% 的人——就他们的用途而言，它简直棒极了。你根本不需要 Excel，你知道的……比如说，当我在多伦多和一些精算师同行一起踢……你叫什么来着，混合性别足球时，我们会把赛程、出勤情况以及谁会出席这些记录都放在谷歌表格里——你根本不需要 Excel 来做那个，那绝对是一件非常精算师风格的事。对，对，或者每当精算师们——在我职业生涯起步的地方，每当我们出去吃……这听起来太逊了，每当我们出去吃一顿比较高档的晚餐或
lunch uh we would like we would just pay all one person would pay and then you'd just keep the receipt and then we would create a sheet and then calculate like the tax and tip and then everyone would just e-transfer. Instead of just like rounding up or down to the closest 10 or 15, like the actuaries, we like to get it right down to the penny. It makes us feel good to open up a spreadsheet just because we can and back out that tip and tax correctly. I do find myself spending a lot of time in the – like I think that the Google Office suite is like the most powerful collaborative tool out there. I would kill for a version of Google Docs but that supports Markdown natively. Like I wrote up this beautiful design document that I sent around last week,
午餐时，我们会……我们会直接由一个人付钱，然后你保留收据，接着我们创建一个表格，计算税费和小费，然后每个人通过电子转账。而不是像普通人那样向上或向下取整到最接近的 10 或 15 块钱，作为精算师，我们喜欢精确到每一分钱。打开电子表格会让我们感觉很好，仅仅因为我们可以做到，并且能正确倒算出小费和税额。我确实发现自己花了很多时间在——我觉得谷歌办公套件是现有的最强大的协作工具。我愿意为了一个原生支持 Markdown 的 Google Docs 版本付出一切。就像我上周写了一份精美的设计文档并发给大家，
and, like, three people replied with, and I just, like, stuck it in GitLab, and three people replied with, like, but how do I leave comments on things? And I'm like, no, this is, like, this is a later draft. The earlier draft was in Google Docs. Now I want it in, like, Markdown so that I can be mores. Now I want it in like Markdown so that I can be
结果有三个人回复说……我把它放到了 GitLab 里，然后有三个人回复说：“但我要怎么在上面留言呢？”我说：“不，这只是一个较晚的草稿。早期的草稿在 Google Docs 里。”现在我希望它是 Markdown 格式的，这样我可以更……现在我希望它是 Markdown 格式的，这样我可以
more precise and I want it in version control. And there were some more complaining. And then I spent my whole day Friday converting this 40 page document back from a Markdown file to a Google Docs file. Like this thing started off its life in Google Docs, got edited a bunch, then it moved to GitLab. And then it finally ended up back again in Google Docs. And I mean, I do love it as a collaborative platform. I just wish it supported Markdown. And I wish it supported references too, like internal references. I wish it supported named internal references.
更精确，而且我希望它能被版本控制。然后还有更多抱怨。于是我花了周五整整一天的时间，把这个 40 页的文档从 Markdown 文件重新转回 Google Docs 文件。这东西的生命周期始于 Google Docs，经过多次编辑，然后移到了 GitLab，最后又回到了 Google Docs。我是说，我确实很喜欢它作为一个协作平台。我只是希望它支持 Markdown。我还希望它支持引用，比如内部引用。我希望它支持命名的内部引用。
You can add bookmarks, but you can't give them a specific name. So it's hard to set up uh proper internal references that's one of the nice things about tools like markdown and bike shed but uh as a collaborative tool yeah google docs is amazing yeah sometimes for it for some things if it needs to be in markdown i'll still still use Google docs. I'll just like make it monospace font and no paragraph formatting. And I'll tell everybody editing it like this is, this is plain text. I know that's in Google docs, but edited as plain text. But, um, if, uh, for certain audiences, people will be sad if it doesn't look pretty, even if it's in Markdown.
你可以添加书签，但你不能给它们指定名称。因此很难设置适当的内部引用，这是 Markdown 和 Bike Shed 等工具的好处之一。但作为协作工具，是的，Google Docs 太棒了。是的，有时对于某些事情，如果它必须是 Markdown 格式的，我仍然会使用 Google Docs。我只会把它设置成等宽字体，不加段落格式。然后我会告诉所有编辑它的人：“这是纯文本。我知道这是在 Google Docs 里，但请把它当成纯文本来编辑。”但是，如果对于某些受众，如果它看起来不够漂亮，人们会感到失望，即使它是 Markdown 格式的。
So that wasn't an option here. So here's the thing, though. We got to talk about two things. One is why do I love Excel so much? Why is it so amazing? But two, I listen to and I've been on a podcast called Talk Python to Me. It's a super popular podcast. A lot of Python folks listen to, and I've been on a podcast called Talk Python to Me. It's a super popular podcast. A lot of Python folks listen to it.
所以在这里这不是一个选项。不过重点是这样的。我们必须讨论两件事。第一，为什么我这么喜欢 Excel？为什么它这么神奇？第二，我听过并且上过一个名为“Talk Python to Me”的播客。这是一个超级受欢迎的播客。很多 Python 爱好者都在听，我曾上过一个名为“Talk Python to Me”的播客。这是一个超级受欢迎的播客。很多 Python 爱好者都在听。
And I'd say like one every three episodes, the host is like trying to convince people that have Excel files and that are building like models in Excel that they need to switch to Python. And it's just this like unusable tool. It's such a mess. You can't, you know, in Python, you can name your variables. You can look things up. In Excel, it's, you know, A1. What does A1 mean? And like there's just this constant sort of like bashing of Excel.
而且我想大概每三期节目中就会有一期，主持人会试图说服那些拥有 Excel 文件并在 Excel 中构建模型的用户切换到 Python。他们会说 Excel 简直是一个无法使用的工具，是一团糟。你不能像在 Python 中那样命名变量，不能进行查找。在 Excel 中，只有 A1 诸如此类。A1 是什么意思？然后就会出现这种对 Excel 的持续贬低。
And I think a part of it is just a lack of understanding. Hang on. If you want to refer to columns with like, if you want to refer to, um, uh, columns with like proper names, not just like a one, you can definitely do that in Excel. I mean, it takes a little setup,
我觉得部分原因只是缺乏了解。等一下。如果你想用像……如果你想用正确的名称来引用列，而不仅仅是 A1，你绝对可以在 Excel 中做到这一点。我的意思是，这需要一点设置，
but so that's, that's what I was going to set. I was setting myself up to do that, but you stole the thunder. But that's, that's the thing is they're like, oh yeah, what is B for me?
但这就是……这就是我正准备要说的。我本来正要这么说，结果你抢了我的风头。但这就是重点，他们会说：“哦，是的，B 对我来说算什么？”
Like, you know, where isn't it Python? You can give that, you can give that a name. Um, and it's like, well,
就像，你知道的，在 Python 中难道不是这样吗？你可以给它起个名字。然后它就像……
no, you can give that a name in Excel too. And then you can like, you can refer to it in other sheets as well. But so the thing is, is there's this like push of consultants that are like offering training and like, oh, the migrate your Excel to Python. And like, I have yet to hear anyone pitch that, that actually understands Excel because a lot of the stuff that they talk about, oh, like, oh, look how much more powerful this is in Python, you can do this, this and that, you can't do that in Excel. Every single time they say something like that, I'm like, you can do that
不，你在 Excel 中也可以给它起名字。然后你也可以在其他工作表中引用它。所以重点是，有一群顾问在推销培训，说什么“把你的 Excel 迁移到 Python”。而且，我还没听到过任何真正懂 Excel 的人提出这种推销，因为他们谈论的很多东西，比如“哦，你看 Python 多强大，你可以做这个、那个，Excel 做不到。”每次他们说这样的话，我都想说：你完全可以在 Excel 中做到这一点。
in Excel. And sometimes it's actually easier to do. So, so the first thing is that, and I actually haven't watched the Simon Peyton Jones, the individual who works on, you know, he's widely acknowledged as sort of being like the father of Haskell, and he works on the GHC compiler. He has a talk called Excel, you know, the purely functional programming language or something like that. I haven't seen it. But I think of Excel, and I probably will give a future talk at some point, as it's like the perfect combination of object-oriented programming in the way that most people think of it, not in the way that Alan Kay intended it to be, and functional programming. So in terms of object-oriented programming, you have at the top level workbooks, and then
而且有时实际做起来甚至更容易。所以，首先是这个。实际上我还没有看过西蒙·佩顿·琼斯（Simon Peyton Jones）的演讲，他是 Haskell 父亲般的人物，并致力于 GHC 编译器。他有一个演讲叫做《Excel：纯函数式编程语言》（Excel, the purely functional programming language）或者类似的名字。我没看过。但我认为 Excel——而且我以后可能会在某个时候做个演讲——它是面向对象编程（以大多数人理解的方式，而不是艾伦·凯（Alan Kay）原本的意图）与函数式编程的完美结合。就面向对象编程而言，在顶层你有工作簿（Workbooks），然后
inside your workbooks, like so a workbook is just an Excel file. Inside your Excel file, you have sheets. And inside your sheets, you have cells. And like every single one of these things has properties that you can control and manipulate using Visual Basic application. And also you can like refer to stuff using just like Excel formula stuff. But like it's a perfect like thing to like give an example of an object oriented system. Like you have one object that's made up of other objects, that's made up of other objects and they all have properties. So that's amazing.
在你的工作簿内部——工作簿只是一个 Excel 文件——在 Excel 文件内部有工作表（Sheets），在工作表内部有单元格（Cells）。而且这里每一个东西都有你可以通过 Visual Basic 应用程序控制和操作的属性。你也可以只使用 Excel 公式来引用各种内容。这简直是展示面向对象系统的一个完美例子：你有一个对象由其他对象组成，那些对象又由其他对象组成，它们都拥有属性。这太棒了。
And then on top of that, the formula where you go equals and then average of, you know, a column, that's like in a certain sense of functional language. It's a very bad functional language because it falls into the inside-out problem where you end up with the average and then inside of a sum if and then a conditional and then you end up with a bunch of parentheses and it's extremely hard to read. But technically that's a functional language. So you've got a functional programming language, an object-oriented model, and then on top
不仅如此，那种输入等号然后求某列平均值的公式，从某种意义上说就是一种函数式语言。它是一种非常糟糕的函数式语言，因为它陷入了内向外（inside-out）的问题，你会得到一个平均值，然后里面嵌套一个条件求和（sumif），然后是一个条件判断，最后你会得到一堆括号，极难阅读。但从技术上讲，它就是一种函数式语言。所以你拥有一个函数式编程语言、一个面向对象模型，然后在
of that there's a ton of other algorithms and things that show up in programming that are like there in Excel. So one example is SumType, aka one of the algebraic data types. There is something called data validation in Python and they have this, or not in Python, in Excel. And they have the same thing in Google Sheets, where basically you can write a list of values, and then in another cell, set it up so that you are validating that the only values that can show up in that cell are in that list. And then what it does is it gives you like a little combo box, which is like, it's so nice. So if you want to set something up, that's like a yes or no option, you just type yes or no in a little list, you data validate it in a cell,
之上还有大量其他算法和编程中常见的概念，它们都存在于 Excel 中。一个例子是 SumType，也就是代数数据类型之一。Python 中有一种叫做数据验证（Data Validation）的东西，它们在 Python 中有，哦不对，不是在 Python 中，是在 Excel 中。谷歌表格中也有同样的东西，基本上你可以编写一个值的列表，然后在另一个单元格中进行设置，验证该单元格中只能出现该列表中的值。然后它会给你一个小组合框（combo box），这太棒了。如果你想设置一个类似于“是”或“否”选项的东西，你只需在一个小列表中输入“是”或“否”，然后在单元格中进行数据验证，
and then it gives you a little drop-down box of your options. That is purely a algebraic data type right there. And it's one of my favorite features of Excel data validation. And Excel has notions of mutability too, because you can protect cells. Yeah, there's this whole like, I'm not sure if it's like reactive programming, but like it's this graph model of where you have a dependencies where, you know, one cell is equal to the sum of a bunch of other cells and those.
它就会为你提供一个包含选项的下拉框。这简直就是一个纯粹的代数数据类型。这是我最喜欢的 Excel 数据验证功能之一。而且 Excel 也有可变性（mutability）的概念，因为你可以保护单元格。是的，这里还有整个……我不确定这算不算响应式编程，但它是一个图模型，你拥有依赖关系，其中一个单元格等于一堆其他单元格的总和。
And so there's this thing of like data tracing where you can trace what cells depend on other cells. So it actually visually shows you the graph, which is like, it's freaking amazing. So like, and people are like, oh, you can never debug. You don't know what depends on what. And it's like, you just, you literally click a button and then it shows you one level of data tracing and then another level and another level. And so like, you can literally see visually on the screen,
还有一个叫做数据追踪（data tracing）的功能，你可以追踪哪些单元格依赖于其他单元格。它实际上会直观地向你展示图表，这简直——太酷了。人们总说：“哦，你永远无法调试。你不知道什么依赖于什么。”而事实是，你只需要点一下按钮，它就会向你展示第一层数据追踪，然后是第二层、第三层。所以你可以直观地在屏幕上看到
like what points to what. The only thing that has even comes remotely close to that in any programming language or IDE that I've seen is Dr. Racket. That if you highlight a variable, if you hover your cursor over a variable in DrRacket, it will draw arrows to every other instance of that variable in your program. And I guess you could technically argue in IDEs and editors, a lot of them when you select a whole word,
什么指向什么。在任何我见过的编程语言或 IDE 中，唯一能与之相比的只有 Dr. Racket。如果在 Dr. Racket 中高亮一个变量，将光标悬停在变量上，它会画出指向程序中该变量所有其他实例的箭头。我想你从技术上讲也可以说，在很多 IDE 和编辑器中，当你选择整个单词时，
it will highlight every other instance of that as well. But you don't get arrows. If something is not on your monitor, you're not going to see like an arrow that's pointing towards it and then there's a whole other like you know we can do a whole other podcast on how basically pandas and rapids kudief is basically just uh pivot tables like pivot tables in excel are groups yeah yeah explain what pivot tables are for those who are not Excel wizards. So basically, a pivot table, you select a table of data where you have columns and rows. So imagine like in your rows, you have a country. And, you know, Canada, America, whatever. It's 200 plus countries in the world.
它也会高亮显示所有其他实例。但你不会得到箭头。如果某个东西不在你的显示器上，你是看不到指向它的箭头的。此外，我们还可以做另一期播客，讲讲为什么 Pandas 和 Rapids cuDF 基本上就是数据透视表——Excel 中的数据透视表就是分组……对，对，请为那些不是 Excel 巫师的人解释一下什么是数据透视表。基本上，数据透视表就是选择一个包含列和行的表格。想象一下，在你的行中有一个国家。比如加拿大、美国什么的。世界上有 200 多个国家。
You got them all. And then in the columns is a bunch of data. So the first column is population. The second column is GDP, whatever. You go on and list a bunch of statistics about each of the countries. You highlight that whole table. You go to, you know, insert pivot table and you'll click next, next, next. And then you're given like an empty window and you can, and then it gives you like all of the options from your columns and your rows that you can drag and drop onto this empty table. And it automatically is going to do like group buys and reductions. So basically, if say you wanted to know in one of the columns, it might say the
你把它们全列出来了。然后在列中是一堆数据。第一列是人口。第二列是 GDP，诸如此类。你列出了每个国家的一系列统计数据。你高亮整个表格。前往“插入数据透视表”，然后点击“下一步、下一步、下一步”。接着你会得到一个空白窗口，然后你可以把你的列和行的所有选项拖放到这个空白表格中。它会自动进行“分组依据（group by）”和“规约（reduction）”。基本上，假设你想在某一列中了解国家所在的
continent that your country is in. So say you want to know the total population in each continent, you can do basically a group by continent. So it's going to group all of the countries together. And then you just specify what's the reduction that you want to do. So you can just do a sum reduction on the population. Like this is the essence of Pandas and, uh, Rapids QDF and like Excel did it first. And before Excel did it, I'm actually not sure. I'm pretty sure SQL came before Excel and Excel Excel pivot tables were just replicating what SQL joins and group bys. That's where I think they all originated. Interesting fact, in my meetup on Monday, the individual who named group by was there.
大洲。假设你想知道每个大洲的总人口，你基本上可以按大洲进行 group by。它会将所有国家分组在一起。然后你只需指定要执行的规约操作。你可以对人口执行求和规约。这正是 Pandas 和 Rapids cuDF 的精髓所在，而且 Excel 最先做到了这一点。在 Excel 之前，其实我不太确定。我确信 SQL 在 Excel 之前就有了，而 Excel 的数据透视表只是在复制 SQL 的 JOIN 和 GROUP BY。这就是我认为它们起源的地方。有趣的事实是，在我周一的聚会上，那个给 GROUP BY 命名的人也在场。
And when I said something about group by, he was like, oh, fun fact, I named that algorithm. And I was like, what? Anyways, so I just, I think it's just, and that's the thing is, so one of the things that on TalkPython to me, the host says, he'll be like, oh yeah, you know, and then in Python, once you've ported your app, you get access to like NumPy and Pandas. Those things are just like, they're just like replications of what you could do previously in Excel. And so anyways, I'll stop my ram my time doing benchmarks and, um, and benchmarking of like lots of low, lots of very low level niche metrics. Like I spent a lot of time working on, uh, uh, task runtime. So I spent a lot of time benchmarking things like, um, user space,
当我提到 GROUP BY 时，他说：“哦，有趣的事实，那个算法是我命名的。”当时我就惊了：什么？不管怎样，我觉得……这就是问题所在。在 Talk Python to Me 上，主持人经常会说：“哦，是的，在 Python 中，一旦你移植了应用，你就可以使用 NumPy 和 Pandas。”这些东西其实只是对你以前在 Excel 中就能做的事情的复制。无论如何，我不再唠叨了，我花了很多时间做基准测试，以及测试许多底层、非常低利基的指标。我花了很多时间研究任务运行时（task runtime）。所以我花了很多时间对用户空间、
context, switching overhead, um, and latencies associated with, uh with task creation, et cetera. And then later I spent a lot of time doing parameter sweeps and tuning of like, you know, what's the right chunk size to use for this algorithm. And I actually, these days we do a lot of that in the libraries that we work with too, that we have, there's a bunch of different accesses that we have to tune all these libraries on and um you just get an explosion of data very quickly so like excel is ideal for um you know like simple benchmarking but once it gets more complex you start thinking oh maybe like i should go should go and write some programs for this. And I spent some period of time writing a series of terrible Python scripts to do this. I do not know how to write good Python.
上下文切换开销，以及与任务创建等相关的延迟进行基准测试。后来我花了很多时间进行参数扫描（parameter sweeps），并调整诸如“针对该算法使用什么样的数据块大小（chunk size）最合适”之类的问题。实际上，如今在我们使用的库中，我们也会做很多类似的事情，我们有很多不同的访问方式来调整所有这些库，你会非常快地遇到数据爆炸。因此，Excel 非常适合用于简单的基准测试，但一旦变复杂了，你就会开始想：或许我应该去为此写一些程序。我曾花了一段时间编写了一系列糟糕的 Python 脚本来做这件事。我其实并不知道怎么写出好的 Python。
So I just wrote bad hacky Python that parsed CSV and spit out more CSV. And I'm a big statistics purist when it comes to uh computer benchmarks if you show me like a benchmark graph and you don't have you know error bars and you don't you don't mention anything about you know your experimental uncertainty um then i'm just like your data is invalid like for all for all i know there like, you know, 50% relative error here and none of these are meaningful. So I always like, I wanted like my little stats package in my Python scripts. And, you know, when I would go and spend two months to get it doing just what I wanted, yeah, like it was pretty great. And then like if I needed to repeat the experiment, it was pretty great.
所以我只写了糟糕、拼凑的 Python，用来解析 CSV 并吐出更多的 CSV。当涉及计算机基准测试时，我是一个坚定的统计学纯粹主义者。如果你向我展示一个基准测试图表，却没有误差条，也没有提及任何关于实验不确定性的内容，那么我就会认为你的数据是无效的。据我所知，这里可能存在 50% 的相对误差，这些数据没有任何意义。所以我总是希望在我的 Python 脚本中加入自己的小统计包。而且，每当我花两个月时间把它调整到我想要的效果时，感觉确实棒极了。如果我需要重复实验，效果也相当不错。
And it was nice to manage all the data in text files and just be able to run Python scripts. But boy, Excel is just like, if you just need to go do something in like five or 10 minutes, Excel is just so much quicker. So one of my rules of thumb for any benchmarking system is it has to output in CSV. And the reason for that is that if you output your data in CSV in a sane fashion, you can copy and paste the data into Excel and it will automatically text to columns without any other work. And so that capability of being able to do a copy and a paste from your raw output to Excel, and I don't mean like copy, paste into Excel,
把所有数据都管理在文本文件中，并且能够直接运行 Python 脚本，这种感觉很好。但是天哪，Excel 就是这样：如果你只需要在 5 或 10 分钟内搞定某件事，Excel 要快得多。所以我的基准测试系统的一个经验法则是：它必须输出 CSV。原因在于，如果你以一种合理的方式输出 CSV 数据，你可以直接将数据复制并粘贴到 Excel 中，它就会自动进行“分列（text to columns）”，而无需任何额外的工作。因此，能够从原始输出直接复制并粘贴到 Excel 中——我指的不是那种复制粘贴到 Excel 之后
and then you have to run text to columns. I mean, you should format your output from a benchmark in such a way that when you paste it into Excel, it is in a sane format there. That is just like so useful because then you can go into Excel and you can set up whatever graphs and metrics, like derived metrics that you want, whatever analysis you want to do. And then the next time when you need to update your data, you can just copy from the output of the script and just paste it right in. You don't even have to mess around with setting up. Excel does have support for external data sources. So you can set that up too. So that like you have some, some cells in your Excel sheet
还必须运行分列功能——我的意思是，你应该以这样的格式格式化基准测试的输出：当你把它粘贴到 Excel 中时，它就已经是一种合理的格式了。这真是太有用了，因为这样你就可以进入 Excel，设置你想要的任何图表和指标、衍生指标，以及你想要进行的任何分析。然后下次你需要更新数据时，你只需从脚本的输出中复制，然后直接粘贴进去。你甚至不需要费心去重新设置。Excel 确实支持外部数据源。所以你也可以进行那样的设置，让 Excel 表格中的某些单元格
that will be read in from some external files. So you can set that up if you want to get fancy, but for a lot of people, you know, that's too much work, but just copying and pasting in is so simple. And so that then it gives you a nice way to, to like get, get, get some benchmark, you know, graphs up and running really quickly and then be able to update them later. Yeah. I think like CSV files, you can just open natively in Excel. You don't even need to copy and paste them. And yeah, like even text to column.
从外部文件读取。如果你想搞得花哨一点，可以这样设置，但对于许多人来说，这工作量太大了，而直接复制粘贴是如此简单。这样就能让你非常迅速地建立并运行一些基准测试图表，并且以后能够轻松更新它们。是的。我觉得像 CSV 文件，你可以直接在 Excel 中打开。你甚至不需要复制和粘贴它们。是的，甚至连分列都不需要。
But if, but if you're going to, if the idea is that is that, like, I'm not just going to have the CSV data, but, like, I want to write some... I want to put a graph into the sheet, or I want to write some, you know, some formulas that use that data. Right, yeah. Yeah, and, yeah, text to column. There's another, like, just extremely useful tool. Oh, yeah.
但是，如果你打算……如果你的想法不仅是拥有 CSV 数据，而是想编写一些……我想在表格中放入图表，或者我想编写一些使用这些数据的公式。没错，是的。是的，还有分列。这是另一个极其有用的工具。哦，是的。
Just for general things. Like, I remember one of the first years i competed in advent of code which i think we've mentioned on a previous uh episode which is just the contest during december problem a day um where you have to solve solve something in whatever programming language you want and like half of the time it's parsing and like i think literally for like it might have even been this year i just solved it in excel because it was it was just like trimming white space and stuff and and the text a column for those that you don't know you basically when you copy and paste something in
仅仅针对常规事情。我记得我参加 Advent of Code（代码降临历）比赛的第一年——我想我们在之前的节目中提到过这个比赛，就是 12 月份每天一道题的比赛，你必须用你想要的任何编程语言来解决某个问题——其中有一半时间都是在做解析。我想甚至就在今年，我直接用 Excel 把题解出来了，因为它只是涉及修剪空白字符之类的事情。对于那些不知道“分列”功能的人来说，当你复制和粘贴某些内容时，
uh if it doesn't automatically go to you know it's not just comma delimited it's you know whatever delimited it'll just paste into a single column you just hit you know alt de which is like the old school you know 2003 shortcut and thank you which is like the old school, you know, 2003 shortcut. And thank you so much, Microsoft. Cause that's the thing. They introduced the ribbon and a bunch of new shortcuts for everything, but they, they grandfathered in, is that an inclusive term? Grandfathered? I'm not sure. No, it's not. It is.
如果它没有自动变成……如果它不仅是逗号分隔的，而是某种分隔符，它就会全部粘贴到单个列中。你只需要按下 Alt+D+E，这是老派的 2003 版快捷键，非常感谢微软。因为就是这样。他们引入了功能区和一堆针对所有功能的新快捷键，但他们保留了……这算是一个包容性词汇吗？“Grandfathered（祖父条款/沿用旧例）”？我不确定。不，不是。是的。
Whatever the inclusive term is for keeping something around, even though they had reinvented it. They kept all the old shortcuts from 2003, which is what I had, like, so I still to this day know, like, you know, I don't know them off, like, it's muscle memory, but they kept them all in, which is just, it's so, I'm so thankful. It's just an amazing thing. And, yeah, yeah, so you're'm so thankful. It's just an amazing thing. And yeah, yeah.
无论保留旧事物的包容性词汇是什么，尽管他们已经对其进行了重新设计，他们还是保留了 2003 年以来的所有旧快捷键。那正是我所习惯的，所以直到今天我依然知道……我甚至不是靠脑子想，那是肌肉记忆，但他们把它们都保留了下来，这真的太棒了。我太感激了。这简直是一件了不起的事情。所以，你会听到我问：“这具有包容性吗？”然后我会把自己剪辑进去说：“事实证明并非如此。请收听下期节目。”但言归正传，回到 Excel。然后我们现在绕回这个话题。你见过、听说过那个在 Excel 里画画的人吗？
So you're going to hear me say, is that inclusive? And then I'm going to cut in myself saying, turns out it's not. Stay tuned for next time. But back to Excel. And then we'll loop back to this point now. Have you seen, have you heard about the guy who paints who like does paintings in Excel?
（笑声）
Yeah, yeah. So we, I will link I'm not sure if it's actually the same thing. There might be multiple Excel artists. All I know is that there's a talk that is given. There's actually, there was an amazing stay on topic. There's a talk that is given there's actually there was an amazing stay on topic there's a talk that uh there's a talk that's been given that demonstrates the power of like yeah
对，对。所以我们会……我会在文末附上链接——我不确定是不是同一个。可能有很多个 Excel 艺术家。我只知道有一个演讲。实际上，有一个精彩的……保持专注。有一个演讲……实际上，有一个精彩的……保持专注。有一个演讲……有一个演讲展示了……的力量。是的，
showing some image um in excel and then i was i've heard of managing up and i've heard of managing down but self-managing? Oh, no, don't go off on that tangent, Connor. That'd be bad. I've not heard that before. Well, it's just because in the midst of talking about this one Excel presentation that is, you know, a conference talk or whatever, it's 15 minutes, I thought about another one that's even more exciting. But the problem about that one is it was internally given at Amazon. And, you know, I won't go into details,
在 Excel 中展示一些图像……我听说过向上管理（managing up）和向下管理（managing down），但自我管理（self-managing）？哦，不，不要扯到那个话题上去，康纳。那可不好。我以前没听说过这个。好吧，那是因为在讨论这个 Excel 演讲（一个会议演讲之类的，有 15 分钟长）的过程中，我想到了另一个更令人兴奋的演讲。但那个演讲的问题在于，它是亚马逊内部进行的。而且，你知道的，我不展开细节，
but basically it was a presentation on machine learning and convolutional neural networks, all given like from the perspective of like, you know, a 10 by 10 grid image in an Excel sheet. And it had some like animations and it was just, it was wonderful.
但基本上那是一个关于机器学习和卷积神经网络的演讲，完全是从一个 10x10 网格图像在 Excel 表格中的视角来讲解的。它还有一些动画，简直太棒了。
Like, you know, Facebook has a really good, I'll try and it was just, it was wonderful. Like, you know, Facebook has a really good, I'll try and get a link to it of like the basics of convolutional neural nets and it shows like, you know, trying to get image recognition for a C versus a D and it just shows a three by three grid. A C is, you know, it's got, what is that? Six of the nine colored,
就像……你知道的，Facebook 有一个非常好的……我试着找一下它的链接……关于卷积神经网络基础知识的介绍，它展示了如何对字母 C 和 D 进行图像识别，它展示了一个 3x3 的网格。字母 C 的话，它有……那是多少？九个格子中有六个是有颜色的，
or no, seven of the nine colored and Or no, seven of the nine colored, and a D has eight of the nine squares colored, all except for the middle one. And basically you end up with a mask that's just a one in the one cell that's different for Cs and Ds, and that's how you, like, distinguish the difference. But, like, the Excel presentation that I saw was like that, except it sort of went into more detail,
或者不对，九个中有七个是有颜色的；而字母 D 有九个中有八个格子是有颜色的，除了中间那个。基本上，你会得到一个掩码（mask），它在 C 和 D 不同的那个单元格中为 1，这就是你如何区分它们差异的方式。但是，我看到的那个 Excel 演讲就像那样，只不过它更详细一些，简直太棒了。那是我看过的一个非常非常棒的内部演讲。是的，我会试着找出我过去看过所有关于 Excel 的演讲。不过话说回来，那个艺术家的演讲非常……是的，我爱 Excel。我爱 Excel。我爱 APL，我也爱 Excel。
and it was just fantastic. It was a really, really good internal talk that I saw. And yeah, I'll try and find all the Excel presentations that I've seen in the past. But yes, the artist one is very... Yeah, I love Excel. I love Excel. I love APL, and I love Excel.
（笑声）
And I failed linear algebra. So what does that say about me? I don't know. All right. So the guy who paints with Excel. So we should explain the basic concept for people that have not heard of this before. You go ahead, man. You're the Excel wizard.
而且我的线性代数不及格。这说明了什么？我不知道。好吧。那么那个用 Excel 画画的人。我们应该为没听过这个概念的人解释一下基本原理。你来吧，老兄。你才是 Excel 巫师。
No, I've spent too much time in the Excel episode. Basically, there's a guy. If I recall, it was like an older guy who makes paintings in Excel by like coloring, individually coloring a bunch of small cells. And then you like you zoom out and it looks like a painting. And like this is his process. I don't remember why he came to this. Doesn't seem super efficient to me,
不，我在 Excel 这一集花的时间太多了。基本上，有这么一个人。如果我没记错的话，好像是一个老年人，他通过给一堆小单元格逐个上色，在 Excel 中创作绘画。然后你缩小看，它看起来就像一幅画。这就是他的创作过程。我不记得他当初是怎么想到这一出的。对我来说这好像不太高效，
but hey, to each their own. I mean, I do a lot of weird like tech things too. Like, you know, like there's not a week that goes by that somebody on my team doesn't tell me like, why are you doing it that way? Why aren't you like using this Vim shortcut or whatever? And I'm like, because I'm old and cranky. I'm not actually old.
不过嘿，各有所好嘛。我的意思是，我也做很多奇怪的技术怪癖。比如，你知道的，我团队里总会有人每周都对我说：“你为什么要那样做？你为什么不用这个 Vim 快捷键或者别的什么？”而我会回答：“因为我又老又暴躁。其实我没那么老，
I am kind of cranky but that's uh that's kind of me i'm i'm bad at tech it's a wonderful piece of software um i'm sure i've even forgotten like 50 of what makes it um oh yeah that's i i totally forgot perfect um there's so many algorithms so uh inner product, aka transform reduced, that's some product equals some product in Excel. The classic stencil example from Thrust. So this is better known as projections in C++20 ranges where basically you're given... So the easiest example is copy if. So copy if, typically you provided a range and a unary predicate and you want to copy all the even elements. But what if you want to
我确实有点暴躁，但这就是我。我不擅长技术。这是一个绝妙的软件，我确信我甚至已经忘记了让它如此优秀的 50% 的原因。哦，对，我完全忘了，太完美了。这里有太多的算法，所以……内积（inner product），也就是变换归约（transform reduce），在 Excel 中就是 SUMPRODUCT（乘积求和）。Thrust 的经典模板示例。这在 C++20 范围（ranges）中更广为人知的名字是投影（projections），基本上你得到的是……最简单的例子就是 copy_if。对于 copy_if，通常你会提供一个范围和一个一元谓词，你想要复制所有偶数元素。但是如果你想要……
copy elements from one range based on the predicate being applied to another range? In thrust, we call that a stencil. In C++ 20 ranges, we call that a projection. That came from Excel. It probably didn't come from Excel, but the first time I discovered it was in Excel, and it's the sum if or insert algorithm underscore if, where you basically give it two ranges of predicate, and then you're summing one range based on some other range. I'll stop there, but the point is there's so many algorithms that exist in programming languages. They're all there in Excel too. And like half the time when I discover an algorithm, I'm like, oh yeah, that's that algorithm from Excel. Because that's where I grew up.
根据应用到另一个区间的谓词来复制一个区间的元素？在 Thrust 中，我们称之为模版（stencil）。在 C++ 20 ranges 中，我们称之为投影（projection）。这个概念源自 Excel。它可能不是来自 Excel，但我第一次发现它是在 Excel 里，也就是 sum if 或 insert algorithm underscore if，基本上就是给它两个谓词区间，然后根据另一个区间来对某个区间求和。我就讲到这里，重点是编程语言中存在着如此多的算法，它们其实在 Excel 里也全都有。而且我大概有一半的时间在发现某个算法时，都会想：哦，对，这就是 Excel 里的那个算法。因为那是我成长的地方。
I grew up in Excel 2003. I probably written like 10,000, 20,000 lines. Oh yeah, and I totally forgot to mention I have like Excel spreadsheets for everything. Yeah, and there is one. I was about to say there's a great spreadsheets for everything yeah and and there there is one i was about to say there's a great teaser here for a future episode we've given this teaser before i think uh connor has this spreadsheet that i don't even know how to describe it it's like a catalog of connor's pursuit of knowledge oh yeah yeah i was wondering which one you're talking about that tells you a lot about connor he just has all of his crucial aspects of his life
我是在 Excel 2003 中成长的。我大概写过一两万行代码。哦，对了，我差点忘了提，我什么东西都有对应的 Excel 表格。对，而且有一个……我正要说，这里有一个针对未来节目的超级大预告，我们之前也给过这个预告，我想……康纳（Connor）有一个表格，我甚至不知道该怎么形容它，它就像是康纳追求知识的目录。哦，对，对，我刚才还在想你在说哪一个。那能说明很多关于康纳的事情，他把他生活中所有至关重要的方面
it's has some spreadsheet so here's what's perfect i have i almost always have this spreadsheet open um and it's called portfolio of words and this. And this, this, this, this, I'm so excited I can't even speak. This Excel spreadsheet, it started back in 2011, the same time when I was at Manulife slash John Hancock. And I'd fallen into the Excel matrix, but then I also had fallen into the world of finance and was like, oh my goodness, there's so much to learn and so I started reading and it
都做成了表格。所以完美的是，我几乎总是开着这个表格，它叫做“词汇档案”（portfolio of words）。而且这个，这个，这个，这个，我太激动了以至于话都说不利索了。这个 Excel 表格始于 2011 年，当时我正在宏利金融（Manulife）兼约翰汉考克（John Hancock）工作。我陷入了 Excel 的矩阵中，但也同时踏入了金融世界，心想：天哪，有太多东西要学了，于是我开始阅读，并且
was at that point that I became a voracious reader and I you know I started reading the big short by Michael Lewis and a bunch of other books you know the essays by Warren Buffett but there was a ton of words that I I just like you can read a book and you'll come across a word and you understand the sentence but if someone asks you to to define one of the words from that sentence, you wouldn't actually be able to define it. What I started doing is while I would read, even if I was on the subway, I'd enter it into my phone on a little notepad and then copy them over to the Excel spreadsheet later.
正是在那时，我成了一个如饥似渴的读者。我开始读迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）的《大空头》（The Big Short）以及一大堆其他的书，比如沃伦·巴菲特的文章。但是里面有大量的词汇，我就是那种……你读一本书时会遇到一个词，你理解那个句子，但如果有人让你定义那个句子里的某个词，你其实根本定义不出来。我开始做的是，在阅读时，甚至在地铁上，我也会把它们记在手机的便签里，然后再把它们复制到 Excel 表格里。
I would keep a list of every single word that I wasn't able to explicitly define. And I've come across some amazing words. One of my favorite words is perspicacious. It means keenly observant. I absolutely love that word. I was hoping we were going to get to your favorite word. And that's, I have to, that one and then ephemeral.
我会保留一份我无法明确定义的每一个单词的列表。我遇到过一些极其精彩的词。我最喜欢的词之一是 perspicacious。它的意思是敏锐的、有洞察力的。我绝对爱死这个词了。我一直在期待我们聊到你最喜欢的词。这个，我必须说，那个，还有 ephemeral。
I love ephemeral too. It means something that is fleeting. It only lasts for, you know, a limited amount of time. You know what word I've really been liking lately is liminal and in particular liminal space. I've never even heard that before. It like, liminal is like, sort of means like transitionary and a liminal space is like a space in between some other
我也很喜欢 ephemeral。它意味着稍纵即逝的事物。它只持续，你知道的，一段有限的时间。你知道我最近真的很喜欢的词是什么吗？是 liminal，特别是 liminal space（阈限空间）。我以前甚至都没听说过。它就像是…… liminal 差不多有过渡性的意思，而 liminal space 就像是介于其他某些
space so like it's like a transitionary space or a transitionary time interesting yeah that's a nice word how do you spell that um l-i-m-i-n-a-l relating to a transitional or initial stage of a process. Damn, so that's, I'm going to have to add it to my sheet. But see, so this is the thing. So it started, this document just started as a list of words. And then I added a tab called books. And it started, and then I started keeping track of the date that I finished a book, all of the books that I wanted to read.
空间之间的空间，所以它就像是一个过渡空间或过渡时期。有意思，对，那是个好词。怎么拼写？呃，l-i-m-i-n-a-l，与某个过程的过渡或初始阶段有关。天哪，所以这个……我得把它加到我的表格里。但你看，事情就是这样。所以它开始时，这个文档只是一个单词列表。后来我加了一个名为“书籍”的标签页，然后我开始记录读完一本书的日期，以及所有我想读的书。
And so there's like literally like six different reading lists. One of them's, most of them are finance ones. One of them's like the Financial Times Book of the Year Award. To this date, I've read, since 2011, I've read 164 books. And then from there, when I started watching cpp con videos i started adding tabs for that and then i started setting goals anyways so the whole thing's exploded this this spreadsheet is like connor's like one so we will do a future episode where connor will share his screen with me and we will review this spreadsheet in its entirety and i will ask questions and it will be
所以这里面字面上有大概六个不同的阅读清单。其中大多数是金融类的。其中一个是《金融时报》年度图书奖清单。截至目前，从 2011 年起，我已经读了 164 本书。从那之后，当我开始看 CppCon 的视频时，我开始为之添加标签页，然后我开始设定目标。总之，整个表格已经膨胀了，这个表格就像是康纳的……所以我们以后会做一期节目，康纳会把他的屏幕分享给我，我们将完整地审阅这个表格，我会提问，那将会是
a great episode yeah there's a couple embarrassing i mean i think uh i think the 50 shades of gray books they're they're in there um so there's there's some uh i'm happy to share it though i mean sometimes when i'm uh that that that was not an optional thing i was i was saying what's gonna happen not asking permission oh look i have an apl, I have an APL. Interesting. I have an APL tab. But that was set up in back of December 2019.
一期非常棒的节目。对，里面有几个挺尴尬的……我是说，我觉得……我觉得《五十度灰》（50 Shades of Grey）的那几本书也在里面，所以有一些……不过我很高兴分享它，我是说，有时当我……那不是一个可选项，我当时是在说接下来会发生什么，而不是在征求同意。哦，看，我有一个 APL，我有一个 APL。很有意思。我有一个 APL 标签页。那是早在 2019 年 12 月设置的。
How many sheets does Portfolio of Words have now? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16. How do I? 17. But a lot of them, a lot of them I never look at. Like, well, yeah, one of them is, it's a sheet called witticisms, which is just little like two word or three word phrases that i would come across in books that i just thought were fantastic and honestly i haven't looked at this in maybe a couple years um do you have a tab for bryce quotes uh i do not um i do have a i do have a file called quotes that i believe there's a couple of quotes from you in um but uh yeah like so in witticisms the first one is infelicitous
“词汇档案”现在有多少个工作表？1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9、10、11、12、13、14、15、16。我怎么……17。但其中很多，我从不看。比如，对，其中有一个叫做“妙语”（witticisms）的工作表，里面只是一些我在书里遇到的两三个词的短语，我觉得棒极了。说实话，我可能已经有好几年没看这个了。呃，你有没有为布莱斯（Bryce）语录设一个标签页？我没有。呃，我确实有一个名为“语录”的文件，我相信里面有几句你的名言。不过，呃，在“妙语”里，第一条是 infelicitous（不恰当的）
remark um number four is intellectual pioneer six is a jocular remark um eight is palpable falsity that's fantastic um ten is mechanistic objectivity whoo that is just rolls off the tongue. A shrewd observer and a judicious writer. Yeah, so these are great. And then I think, oh yeah, warm-up words. And so I have another tab. So I used to, this is getting way off in the weeds. I used to do professional theater. We never do that.
言论。第四条是“思想先驱”。第六条是“诙谐的言论”。第八条是“显而易见的谬论”，这太棒了。第十条是“机械的客观性”，哇，这真是朗朗上口。一个精明的观察者和一个明智的作家。对，这些都很棒。然后我想，哦对了，“热身词汇”。所以我还有另一个标签页。所以过去，这话题扯得太远了。我以前演过专业话剧。我们从不那样做。
We never get off in the weeds. Anyway, tell us about your acting days. Well, that'll be a whole other episode. But the point is that you learn phrases that are difficult to pronounce. And the one that everyone has heard of, or I would assume a lot of people have heard of, maybe not everyone,
我们从不扯太远。总之，跟我们讲讲你的演艺生涯吧。嗯，那将是另外一整期节目。但重点是，你会学到一些很难发音的短语。大家都听说过的那一个，或者我假设很多人都听说过，可能不是每个人都听过，
is tip of the tongue, the teeth, the lips. So that's what after say... Never heard of it before. Really? Never heard of it before. And my father's a theater director. Yeah, you're from New York, bro. I'm surprised you haven't seen that.
就是“舌尖、牙齿、嘴唇”（tip of the tongue, the teeth, the lips）。这就是要说……我以前从没听过。真的吗？从来没听过？我父亲还是戏剧导演呢。对，你是从纽约来的，兄弟。我很惊讶你没见过这个。
I'm a theater director. Yeah. Yeah, tip of the tongue, the teeth teeth the lips so i i had heard that one before um the one that i learned from my theater days was unique new york um to try and say that like five times fast like unique new york unique new york unique new york you try now bryce this will be fun new york new york unique new york unique new york unique new york unique yeah yeah it's hard well it's already well established that i am bad at pronouncing things that's well it's when i started doing it you get like one word into it and then you fumble you really have to you really have to practice it and so i set up this tab that when i came across words that i had trouble pronouncing uh i would
我是一个戏剧导演。对。对，“舌尖、牙齿、嘴唇”，所以我以前听过那个。呃，我从戏剧生涯中学到的是“Unique New York”（独特的纽约），试着像这样快速说五遍：“Unique New York, Unique New York, Unique New York”。布莱斯，你现在试试，这会很有趣。New York, New York, Unique New York, Unique New York, Unique New York, Unique。对，对，这很难。好吧，大家已经很清楚我本就不擅长发音。这就是……当我开始做的时候，你刚说了一个词就舌头打结了。你真的必须，你真的必须练习它。所以我设置了这个标签页，当我遇到发音有困难的单词时，我就会
just add it so like the first three are interdisciplinary, sole proprietorship, and hierarchical. And then number 13 is unlexicographically. When I first read that word, I was like, WTF, what is this? One of the ones that's tough for me is amicable. And there's a few others that are sort of like that. Amicable? Yeah.
把它加进去。比如前三个是 interdisciplinary（跨学科的）、sole proprietorship（独资企业）和 hierarchical（分等级的）。然后第 13 个是 unlexicographically（非词典编纂学地）。我第一次读到这个词时，心想：WTF，这是什么？对我来说比较难的一个词是 amicable（友好的）。还有其他一些类似的词。Amicable？对。
You have trouble with amicable? Yeah. There's a couple others in that family. Amicable? Yeah. You have trouble with amicable? Yeah. There's a couple others in that family. There's another one that I'm thinking of that I have, there's another one that I have trouble with that I can't remember what the word is because I'm old. So we've established. Yeah, lexicographer.
你对 amicable 发音有困难？对。那个家族里还有另外几个。Amicable？对。你对 amicable 发音有困难？对。那个家族里还有另外几个。我还想到另一个我有发音困难的词，但我记不起那个词是什么了，因为我老了。所以我们已经确定了这一点。对，lexicographer（词典编纂者）。
Yeah, I don't even know if that's lexicographer. I think I'm pronouncing that right. Oh, then yeah. And then sometimes saying words side by side. So like commensurate and commensurable. And then commensurately and commensurably. And I think I may be messing that up. But yeah, these are great. Excel. So we didn't even get, I was going to mention, and we'll end here because your girlfriend's going to kill you. She's not back yet um but she's gonna come in and i'm gonna be well excel is amazing and she's gonna be like what's going on um but so uh two different programs that i wrote that were extremely useful um over time um was one was a study tool when I was studying for my actuarial exams.
对，我甚至不知道那是不是 lexicographer。我想我发音是对的。哦，那就对了。有时候把意思相近的词放在一起说，比如 commensurate（相称的）和 commensurable（可公度的）。还有 commensurately 和 commensurably。我想我可能把它们搞砸了。不过，对，这些都很棒。Excel。所以我们还没聊到……我本来要提的，我们就在这里结束，因为你女朋友要杀了你了。她还没回来，但她等会儿进来时，我会……好吧，Excel 太棒了，她会问“怎么回事”。所以，我写过的两个极其有用的程序，随着时间推移……其中一个是当我准备精算师考试时的学习工具。
And Excel is so amazing because in the VBA code, you can execute shell scripts. And so basically what I did is I had like all of these questions that were loaded in from a study guide. And they would have like an abbreviated answer and then link to a page in a PDF for like the full-blown context to review. And so what I did is I got all these questions into an Excel spreadsheet and I set up some macro buttons. And so it would just randomly generate like a pop-up window with a question. And then I would answer it myself in my head. And then you could click a button in the pop-up window called answer and that would execute a shell script, which would use the Sumatra PDF,
Excel 太神奇了，因为在 VBA 代码中，你可以执行 shell 脚本。所以基本上我做的是，我把从学习指南中加载的所有这些问题放进去。它们会有一个简短的答案，然后链接到 PDF 中的某个页面以获取用于复习的完整上下文。所以我的做法是将所有这些问题导入到 Excel 表格中，并设置了一些宏按钮。这样它就会随机弹出一个包含问题的窗口。然后我在脑子里自己回答。接着你可以在弹窗中点击一个名为“答案”的按钮，这会执行一个 shell 脚本，该脚本会使用 Sumatra PDF，
which is only available on Windows. It's not available on Linux. And it had like, if you opened it up on the command line, you could pass it like a flag with a page number. And so I would click this button for Answer and it would launch me the PDF file to the exact page with the answer on it. And it was freaking fantastic.
它只在 Windows 上可用。在 Linux 上不可用。如果你在命令行中打开它，你可以向它传递一个带有页码的参数。所以当我点击这个“答案”按钮时，它就会把 PDF 文件直接打开到写有答案的那一页。这真是太棒了。
It was fantastic. And I was just like, when people would see me and they're like, what are you doing? This is like these PDFs popping up and shutting down. And it was just the best. And then I also built a study tool when I was learning Chinese that had so many different modes. Cause that was the thing.
这真是太棒了。每当人们看到我时，都会问：你在干什么？这些 PDF 弹出来又关掉的。这简直是绝了。然后当我学习中文时，我也构建了一个学习工具，它有非常多的不同模式。因为关键就在于此。
You just, you'd put like the word in one column and then the Chinese character, the pinyin, which is the phonetic translation, the definition. And then I had modes where I was just practicing Chinese reading, where I was practicing the pinyin, the pronunciation. And the beauty of building these tools is that you could gamify it. So you could set up a tab or a little graph that while you're generating these pop-up windows, so like the word, you know, woe shows up on the screen in the Chinese character, which means I in Chinese. And so then you can say woe, which is – it has the third tone, which is like a little up and down.
你只需要把单词放在一列中，然后是汉字、拼音（即语音翻译）、定义。然后我有各种模式，比如我只是在练习中文阅读，在练习拼音、发音。构建这些工具的美妙之处在于你可以将其游戏化。所以你可以设置一个标签页或一个小图表，当你生成这些弹窗时，比如屏幕上显示出汉字“我”（wo），意思是汉语中的 I。然后你可以说 wo，它是——它有第三声，就像一个小升降调。
And so you have little like checkbox check boxes for what you got right. Did you pronounce it right? Did you get the actual word right? Maybe you can't recognize it. And then over time, in the little graph, it'll show you what your percentage of right and wrong is. And then you can set up color highlighting that if you're above 80%, you have a nice little green box.
所以你有小勾选框来记录你答对了什么。你发音对了吗？你把实际的单词答对了吗？也许你认不出来。然后随着时间的推移，小图表会向你展示你的正确率和错误率百分比。接着你可以设置颜色高亮，如果高于 80%，你就会有一个漂亮的绿色小方框。
And if you're below 80%, you have a yellow box. And if you're below 50%, you have a nice little green box. And if you're below 80%, you have like a yellow box. And if you're below 50%, you have like a red highlighted box. It's fantastic. You look bored, Bryce, but I tell you, it's the best. It's the best. Connor, I am never bored when you're excited. But yeah, that's just a couple of the spreadsheets. And the same way that I feel about all programming languages and that we should be kind to whatever insert programming language,
如果低于 80%，你就会有一个黄色方框。如果低于 50%，你就会有一个漂亮的绿色小方框。如果低于 80%，你就会有一个黄色方框。如果低于 50%，你就会有一个红色高亮方框。这太棒了。布莱斯，你看起来很无聊，但我告诉你，这绝对是绝佳的。这绝对是绝佳的。康纳，当你兴奋的时候，我绝不会觉得无聊。不过，这只是其中的几个表格。就像我对所有编程语言的看法一样，我们应该对任何插入的编程语言保持善意，
you know, Perl. Everyone loves to hate on Perl. And I love Perl. The little I know about Perl, I love it. When I worked at LSU, there was this professor, Steve Brandt, was one of the guys I worked with, and he was a PL guy. You and him would get along very well. Yeah, you and him would get along, like, troublingly well.
你知道，比如 Perl。每个人都喜欢痛恨 Perl。而我热爱 Perl。我对 Perl 虽知之不多，但我爱它。我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）工作时，有一位教授叫史蒂夫·布兰特（Steve Brandt），是我共事过的人之一，他是个 PL（编程语言）高手。你和他的关系会非常融洽。对，你和他的关系会融洽得让人觉得有点问题。
But he knew how to write Pearl. And if you wanted a script that did some like you know something like you know some some some typical lennox hackery thing like you could just send steve an email roughly describing what you'd want and like five minutes later a like pearl script with like no white space and like as few lines as possible would be sent back to you and you wouldn't know how it would work but it would do exactly what you wanted yeah that's awesome uh i've heard yeah i've heard pearl was it i heard it used to be like an absolutely loved language back in the day when it first came out.
但他确实懂得如何编写 Perl。如果你想要一个能实现某种……你知道的，某种典型的 Linux 黑客风格脚本，你只需给史蒂夫发一封电子邮件，大致描述一下你想要什么，大约五分钟后，一个几乎没有空格、行数尽可能少的 Perl 脚本就会发回给你。你虽然不知道它是怎么工作的，但它能完全实现你想要的功能。对，太棒了。我听说，对，我听说 Perl 以前是一门在它刚问世时备受喜爱的语言。
We should do an episode on it sometime because it used to be really popular. I think it has a few really good features going for it, and then it's become a lot less popular recently. So it'd be interesting to do an episode on the history of Perl. Perl has one of the properties, and we're going to do an episode on Bash someday. Perl and Bash have a similar property, which I really like, which is one of the reasons why I'm such a big fan of Bash is Bash makes it very easy to invoke other processes and to like chain them together.
我们什么时候应该做一期关于它的节目，因为它曾经真的很受欢迎。我认为它有一些非常优秀的特性，只是最近变得没那么受欢迎了。所以做一期关于 Perl 历史的节目会很有趣。Perl 具备某种特性——我们以后某天会做一期关于 Bash 的节目——Perl 和 Bash 有一个相似的特性，我非常喜欢，这也是我如此大程度支持 Bash 的原因之一，那就是 Bash 让调用其他进程并将它们串联起来变得非常容易。
And as does Perl. Like if you've ever done any scripting in Python, you know, Python's great, but it is a bit more verbose and a bit more work to construct, like to cobble together a task by invoking a bunch of other programs in Python. You have to go through a more verbose, you know, subprocess API, whereas in both Bash and Perl, the idea of invoking other tools and processes is a much more inherent part of the language. You know what we should do? We should try and get Larry Wall. Let's try and get the creator of Perl to come on our podcast. We'll have Sean Parent on first, and then we'll have Larry Wall wall on and uh sean that's this is your this is
Perl 也是如此。如果你用 Python 写过任何脚本，你知道的，Python 很棒，但通过在 Python 中调用一堆其他程序来拼凑一个任务，会显得有些啰嗦，编写起来也需要更多的工作。你必须经历更啰嗦的子进程（subprocess）API，而在 Bash 和 Perl 中，调用其他工具和进程的概念是语言本身更固有的一部分。你知道我们应该做什么吗？我们应该试着请来拉里·沃尔（Larry Wall）。让我们试着邀请 Perl 的创造者来我们的播客。我们先请肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent），然后再请拉里·沃尔，呃，肖恩，这是给你的
your notice that uh you were going to be the first guest on our podcast we're not sure when but uh we can't we can't not have him as our first guest on because that just it wouldn't be right it's like the planets would be misaligned and um something it can be like sean then tony then larry oh yeah also yeah do you want to while we're wrapping up, there was a lot of discussion last week on the What Goes in a Standard Library episode. Anything you'd like to say to the folks at large? I will say I have no edits to my stance, and I will be giving a talk at C++ Now called What Belongs in the C++ Standard Library.
通知，呃，你将成为我们播客的第一位嘉宾。我们不确定是什么时候，但呃，我们不能不让他当我们的第一位嘉宾，因为那样就不对了。这就好比行星错位了，呃，某些东西……可以先是肖恩，然后是托尼，然后是拉里。哦，对，还有，在我们收尾之际，上周关于“标准库里应该有什么”那一集引发了大量讨论。对于广大听众，你有什么想说的吗？我要说的是，我对自己的立场没有任何修改，我将在 C++ Now 大会上发表题为《什么应该属于 C++ 标准库》的演讲。
And I expect that talk to be exactly in line with my tweets. That's where we'll call it. Thanks for listening. We hope you have a great day and we'll see you in the next episode. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我预计那场演讲的内容将与我的发推完全一致。我们就聊到这里。感谢收听。希望你们度过美好的一天，我们下期节目再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。